welcome back to the cyber security
architecture Series in previous videos
we covered security principles some of
the foundational Concepts and then we
started talking about different cyber
security domains like identity and
access management and endpoint security
and network security today we're going
to talk about application security so
let's get started what are some of the
things that we need to consider in this
why do we have to care maybe is the best
question well it turns out that
essentially all software has bugs nobody
writes a software of any real complexity
that's error-free and it turns out that
some percentage of those bugs will be
security vulnerabilities
so therefore if you follow the logical
conclusion that means essentially all
software is going to have security
vulnerabilities in it so what can we do
to try to reduce those and why do we
need to do it obviously we don't want
buggy software and we don't want
security issues but this will help Drive
the point home a little bit I think if
we look at the various stages of
application development and look at
where security or vulnerabilities in
general are introduced think about the
injection phase it turns out that most
of the vulnerabilities and bugs are
introduced in the coding phase which is
not surprising and then as we move to
unit test functional test System test
and release then we find fewer and fewer
bugs so that's the the green curve but
that's when they're introduced when are
they found well they're found as we kind
of move along this process during the
coding phase is when we're introducing
them but not finding them in the testing
phase we're finding them and then
hopefully when we get to the real world
we don't find quite so many now the
interesting thing about all of this is
the cost how does the cost go well it
turns out cost goes about like this
where we go from 1X as the whatever you
want to base the cost to fix a bug down
here in the coding phase to in some
cases
640x it is vastly more expensive to fix
a vulnerability once it's in the field
than it is to catch it early so there's
a huge incentive for us to get this
right and get it early now what can we
do then in order to get this done more
quickly well let's take a look
traditional we're going to take a look
by the way at this software development
life cycle that's the sdlc and
traditionally this is how it's been done
we have some design phase here where
we're going to figure out in general
what we're going to do in this
particular application and then we're
going to move to a coding phase we're
going to write the application itself
then we're going to go to some point
sort of testing phase and then
ultimately we release it to the world
and put it in production now what has
traditionally happened is there's a big
line separating these two where this is
the dev part of the process and this is
the Ops part of the process this is
where we're developing this is where
we're releasing and then just operating
it and running it in a continuous State
the problem with this traditional
approach is that it's very linear you
can see how this process goes it's also
very siled this line right here could be
very thick in some organizations
and it it kind of leads to this sort of
over-the-wall mentality I'm going to
write the code and then I'm going to
throw it over there and make them
operate it and so there's not a lot of
communication Happening Here it can be a
slow process and it's fairly inflexible
and by the way I'm going to suggest to
you we didn't really introduce security
very early in this process very often
security gets introduced out here and
that's a problem now a more modern
approach to this is this thing called
devops so here we take the two processes
Dev where we're building the code then
we're releasing it we're deploying it
we're operating it and we're feeding
back with a devops process now what
we've got is a cyclical type of
situation this thing doubles back on
itself there's a feedback loop of
continuous Improvement there's no over
the wall there's no US versus them it's
an integrated process it's much more
rapid and it's designed for agility so
this is a much more Flex flexible kind
of capability moving away from this
traditional linear approach
but again we haven't really addressed
the security here and so what more
modern approaches have done is introduce
this notion of Dev secops where now
we're going to basically bathe or
Encompass the whole thing in a security
layer
we're going to put security at every one
of these phases we don't want this to be
something that we wait to the End
security can't be a bolt-on that is not
going to be effective we need security
to be built in and looked at at every
one of these phases so for instance with
a devsecops approach we're going to do
what is referred to as shift left
thinking that's if you were thinking of
this in a linear phase or thinking of it
this way then we're going to put
security not just here we're going to
introduce security at each one of these
phases
we're going to do security by Design
we're going to design the system so that
it stands up and it's resilient to
attack from the first not again as a
bolt-on then we're going to create
collaboration among what have been
traditionally three different groups
that maybe didn't always talk together
but with devsecops we have it all
working together with a lot of
collaboration a lot of feedback and then
ultimately try to leverage a lot of
automation I'll talk about that in terms
of tooling a little bit later in the
video
okay now we've covered the software
development life cycle next we're going
to take a look at secure coding
practices and things like that what do
we need in order to write secure code if
we're going to shift security left all
the way to the coding maybe even design
phase well we're going to focus on the
coding part right here what are my needs
well one thing I need is a list of
secure coding practices this is a
prescriptive way of saying this is how
we should go about writing certain code
there are certain things that we need to
do for instance validate inputs we need
to make sure that if a buffer has been
allocated for this size for input that
when someone sends me something it's not
this big because then in that case it
could be overriding memory we call this
a buffer overflow so that's a type of
condition that's been around for a long
time if we don't do all the input
checking we could have problems we need
to specify how we would do
authentication what are some of the
other ways that we would use
cryptography what kinds of error
handling routines so it's basically a
way of saying have we checked off all of
these things have we done them all
correctly well there's a great resource
here it's called o wasp
dot org
and at this website what you'll find is
they have a list of secure coding
practices they have a very good document
that is kind of an industry standard
that a lot of people use in this so I
would reference that you take a look
there trusted libraries everyone doesn't
write all their code from scratch
anymore because there's just too much
that needs to be done so as a result we
end up relying on code that's been
written by other people it might be open
source it might be proprietary but we're
going to use this in our code as well or
make calls to it and leverage it there's
a lot of sources that are out there but
not all of them are trustworthy and even
the trustworthy ones need to be looked
at with a certain amount of skepticism
and a certain amount of inspection so
trusted libraries are an important thing
here as well and if you want to see what
can happen even with a trusted Library
go look up something called
log4j this is a very well known
vulnerability that affected tons and
tons of systems because everyone was
used using this routine which was a
common trusted routine from trusted
sources and yet it had a vulnerability
in it that an attacker could exploit and
those vulnerabilities were discovered
guess what over here in this phase right
when it was the most expensive after it
had been released so again we want to
try to to eliminate that or at least
find it much earlier in the process if
we can and using trusted sources at
least helps it doesn't eliminate the
risk but it helps standard architectures
I want to have spelled out that when
we're going to do a certain approach
this is how the system should look so we
want to spell out in advance what those
would look like there's a lot of
different sources for that IBM has an
application security architecture
reference website that you can take a
look at we'll reference here also there
are other sources but you want to be
able to spell this out for your whole
organization so that they can see that
mistakes to avoid again we're going to
go back to our friends at owasp they
have a thing called the owasp top 10
list and what's really interesting in
this is they're showing what are the top
10 vulnerabilities that we keep seeing
and it's very interesting to look at
this over time look back in 2017 what
were the top 10 and look now and and the
more recent one 2021 and what you'll
find is there's been a little bit of
Shifting here but unfortunately it's
sort of the same list which means we're
not getting better we're not making
these defects extinct we're just kind of
shuffling the order a little bit but
things like buffer overflows and other
types of input validation errors have
been around for a long time but this is
a great Learning Resource so again I
refer you to owasp and then finally this
notion is really starting to build some
momentum the idea of a software bill of
materials that is I want to know where
everything came from kind of a supply
chain if you think of it this way I want
to know all the components that I'm
using I want to know where they came
from their Origins the libraries that
they came from and where those are
sourced I want to know what dependencies
exist amongst these different components
and have those really spelled out I
don't want any surprises in that I want
to know the versions of all of these
that I've used across all of my
different systems and if I'm building
applications I need to know which
versions are used because those will
change over time need to be updated and
I need to be able to know what
vulnerabilities might exist in those
again refer to log4j go and do a web
search on that if you want to find out
more about that example that's a good
example where if we have a software bill
of materials and we get hit by one of
those vulnerabilities then we have a
much better idea of all the different
place is that we need to make changes
and we can recover much more quickly and
hopefully eliminate a certain amount of
this cost
okay now we've covered the software
development life cycle secure coding and
we're now going to take a look at
vulnerability testing we'd like to test
for security throughout the process
remember one of the things I mentioned
in the devsec Ops process is to use more
automation that is use more tooling and
two major classes of those tools are
static application security testing SAS
and dast dynamic application security
testing you figured if a one was going
to be static the other is going to be
dynamic right okay what's the difference
in those two well the static is often
referred to as white box testing it's
called that because we can look inside
and feed it the source code so it's like
it's looking inside our code so the
boxes is open in that sense the Black
Box Dynamic instead of giving it source
code we're actually obscuring what the
source code is it's going to look at an
executable system think about it
differently in this this case we're
going to do maybe after the coding phase
I can run one of these tools I can feed
my source code into it and it will look
for vulnerabilities and tell me about
those the ones that it can identify and
the great thing about that is we're
moving this much earlier we're doing a
shift left in the dev process and
finding those bugs at the earliest stage
that they were introduced therefore
reducing cost
even if I can't do it in that phase I'd
at least like to catch it during one of
these test phases so it's a little bit
later in the development cycle but it's
still before we hit release when
everything gets super expensive so what
I'd like to do is run both of these in
other words it's not an either or it's
really both
and
because there's advantages to both of
these the the source code scanner will
find certain types of vulnerabilities
the dynamic scanner will find other
types so you really need to use them
both together and you use them
throughout this process and again think
about that cyclical devsecops process
and you can see how this would fit in
and how the tools now become the enabler
to do better security
one other sort of tool that's being used
in this space a lot for application
development it wasn't initially thought
of in that context by a lot of people
but it's really becoming popular and
that is chat Bots these large language
models with with uh generative
capabilities can also generate code so a
chat bot is is good at generating code
very quickly you could say write me a
routine in say python that will find all
the ways to make change for a dollar and
it'll spit it right out just like that
so that's a nice feature that you can
have the chat bot write code for you it
can also debug code so if I've got stuck
at some point during the development of
of some routine I could send it into a
chat bot and maybe it will find what my
vulnerability is or what the bug is that
I'm trying to deal with so that's all
good stuff however there's a downside
the downside is it could also
potentially inject vulnerabilities so
that is when we get source code back we
could inspect that but probably you went
to the chat bot because you had a lot of
code you wanted it to write for you not
just 12 lines of code because that you
could have done on your own so are you
going to inspect all of that and make
sure that the chat bot either didn't
make a mistake then introduces a
vulnerability or maybe it's been
engineered in a way or someone has
hacked it and it's intentionally putting
a back door in so that all of your data
is shared out with someone else or that
malware is introduced without your
knowledge so that's a big risk it's not
necessarily a trusted Source like an
open source Library where we've had
potentially thousands of eyes looking at
it and inspecting it in this case it
just came right straight from the source
and now you're putting it right into
your code so there's a big risk there
and another thing is if I'm using it to
do debugging then that means I'm feeding
my source code into this system and this
system might expose intellectual
property if this code I have is
considered a content Financial if it's a
trade secret if it's something that we
might copyright now I've just taken that
and I've given it directly to what is
essentially to the internet potentially
because it can now take that information
and learn on it it might use it it might
reuse your code in some other case there
was one major company that in fact had
that happen to them where their
developers were using a chat bot to do
debugging and uh it turned out they were
releasing their proprietary source code
into the system and the company decided
that's not really what we want to be
doing so we need to stop that okay so
that's a quick look at application
security what we've tried to cover are
ways to introduce process uh do a more
continuous process and use Tooling in
order to improve the security of our
systems and Leverage The Best of the
learning from sources like owasp so that
we don't keep making the same mistakes
over and over again it feels a lot if
you've been doing security like the
movie Groundhog Day we just keep
reliving the same problems over and over
and over again so let's learn from those
and use those good resources to not keep
doing that
so now we've covered application
Security in our next video we're going
to move over to cover data security
which is the crown jewels that's the
thing that we ultimately need to protect
in most of these cases and so that you
don't miss that make sure that you hit
like subscribe and notify and that way
you'll catch the next video when it
comes out
thank you